these residents are returning to their
villages in the cyclone hit region of
Arya poly on India's East Coast many
people here have lost everything saqlain
pilan made landfall with wind speeds of
up to 200 km/h it uprooted trees and cut
power lines and communications most of
the casualties were caused by flying
branches and debris yea though many of
us thought we wouldn't make it also will
take again we just didn't know what else
would happen there was so much
destruction petoskey and that's another
primary concern at the moment is to look
for survivors communication has been
crippled we are not in touch with the
district administration it's I mean it's
it's very logical that this should have
happened the damage is catastrophic but
the major loss of life that has
accompanied cyclones in this region in
the past has been avoided the last time
a storm of this severity hit the region
was in 1999 up to ten thousand people
died as a result this time authorities
were better prepared people living in
that threatened coastal areas were
evacuated to higher ground in one of the
biggest evacuation efforts in India's
history almost a million people were
moved to safety in schools and temples
that served as shelters now those with
nothing left are receiving food Russians
many of these people lived in simple
Hut's that were swept away by the storm
around 600,000 people in the state of
erisa are now homeless